okay everyone let's talk about project
Argos new co-op mode which will hit a
lot of nostalgic beats for you
old-school shooter fans out there with
it's tough BOTS and open terrain
it'll also remind you of how far more
recent games have come with basic
features like vaulting clearly
understood progression hit animations
and one really bad thing that we'll talk
about in a second while I honestly like
the idea of a more casual version of
ARMA argoes development still has a long
way to go to get away from the base
games rough edges as it stands right now
the game's biggest design problem is the
inability to quickly tell friend from
foe by either silhouette or uniform this
combined with being free-to-play has led
to rampant team killing mistrust between
players and ultimately a bad experience
games like Rainbow six siege took a
while but eventually implemented fair
team killing kicks and bands that need
to be an Argo furthermore as it stands
right now co-op easy mode does not award
skill tree or weapon on my progress
which makes it pretty pointless to do
even in a free game fortunately Argo is
in early access and in development so
many of these features could change over
time which is good because maybe outside
of the dragon Rising series and
planetside 2 there just isn't much out
there like Argo when it comes to large
group mission based co-op I'm going to
leave you with the intro cinematic some
combat and open up the comments to your
ideas what features from more modern
shooters do you think could bring our go
up to speed or have games like player
nones battlegrounds squad and insurgency
just made the idea of Argo obsolete as
always likes and subs are appreciated
thanks everyone let's get to it
[Music]
[Music]